في هذه الأثناء، يتخذ بوتين الآن في روسيا
إجراءات جديدة وأكثر تطرفًا ضد
الأمريكيين، وجاء في بيان على
الموقع الإلكتروني لوزارة الخارجية الروسية ما يلي:
وأقتبس من المواطنين الأمريكيين الخاضعين
لعقوبات شخصية بما في ذلك حظر
الدخول إلى الاتحاد الروسي
ويستمر في إدراج 500 شخص خاضعين لعقوبات
أن الحكومة الروسية، بما فيهم أنا،
أصدرت أيضًا تحذيرًا بهذا
الإعلان وتقول، أقتبس، لن
يمر هجوم عدائي واحد ضد روسيا دون رد فعل قوي، ولهذا
السبب فإن تغطية هذه الحرب كل ليلة
أمر مهم وسنواصل القيام بذلك
لأن هناك شيئًا مهمًا للغاية بالنسبة لنا.
كلنا يحدث في أوكرانيا
وأيضًا داخل روسيا، حيث
ينقلب حلفاء بوتين الليلة على أنفسهم
ويطلبون من أولئك الذين ينتقدون
حرب بوتين أن يلتزموا الصمت،
كل هؤلاء المذعورين المذعورين يمكنهم
التمسك بها حيث لا تشرق الشمس،
يجب أن يهدأوا.  من
المؤكد أننا في بعض الأحيان نرتكب أخطاء فادحة ولكن من
لا يفعل ذلك، فما رأيك في أن ندعم انتقاداتنا
ونحتفظ بالانتقادات في مطبخك الخاص